.
Was ich gesehen habe,
hat meine Erwartungen voll erfüllt.
Die Bilder, die Videochats
und dann die Realität.
Sie wäre meine Frau gewesen.
Mir war wichtig,
dass meine Kinder auch
die Heimat ihrer Mutter
kennenlernen.
Sie sollen auch lernen,
wie es dort läuft.
Als wir unsere Beziehung anfingen,
war meine Mutter sehr beeindruckt:
"Oh, ein Ausländer, ein Schweizer!"
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
# Forever you and me.
Wo sind wir hier?
Hier ist der Makola Market.
Achtung!
* Hupen *
Mit Mefia Ehrensperger
bin ich auf dem grössten Markt
Westafrikas unterwegs.
Hier findet man alles,
wirklich alles.
Schnecken, schau mal!
Wow!
Hast du das schon gegessen?
Ja, immer gleich zwei.
- Wirklich? Immer?
Wenn so eine in meinem Garten wäre,
würde ich tot umfallen.
Wow!
Willst du eine mitnehmen?
- Nein!
Nach Hause nehmen? Nein!
- Nicht?
Sie will zu dir.
Whoa!
Afrikanische Landschnecken
sind in Ghana eine Delikatesse.
Aber nichts für mich.
* Lockere Musik *
* Sie sprechen
in einer Fremdsprache. *
Diese Stoffe will Mefia
als Wanddekoration für ihr Hotel.
Und sie wird gleich noch mal fündig.
Quittungsbelege für die Gäste.
Ich habe dich als sehr
freundliche Person kennengelernt.
Aber als Geschäftsfrau musst du auch
tough sein können, nicht?
Manchmal bin ich schon
etwas strenger.
Es hängt vom Gast ab.
Ist er freundlich, bin ich es auch.
Wenn nicht,
kann ich auch strenger sein.
So, let's go!
- Let's go.
Auf dem Parkplatz
treffen wir Mefias Mann Beda.
Er macht im Auto gerade einen Deal.
Dicke Notenbündel
wechseln den Besitzer.
So geht Geldwechseln in Ghana.
Warum machen wir das so?
Ist das semilegal?
Bei uns in der Schweiz
wechselt man ja auf einer Bank Geld.
Ja. Aber auf der Bank
hat man den schlechteren Kurs.
Okay.
Beda bewegt sich in Ghana
schon fast wie ein Einheimischer.
Dabei lebt er mit seiner Familie
erst seit drei Jahren hier.
Das erste Mal kam er vor 17 Jahren
nach Accra.
Nach dem Musikstudium
lernte er hier das Trommelspielen.
Wenn eine Trommel kaputt ist,
bringt er sie zu Odarte Thunderdrums,
einem Meister seines Fachs.
(Lachend) Here I am.
Guten Tag, Odarte.
- Beda!
Willkommen.
Lange her!
Ah, eine Trommel.
Ja, wir brauchen wieder mal
eine Ziege.
Eine Seite Ziege und eine Plastik.
Ja, die lassen wir so.
Gehen wir zusammen
ein Trommelfell kaufen.
Zu Beginn führten Mefia und er
eine Fernbeziehung
zwischen der Schweiz und Ghana.
Als ich zurückkehrte,
um Mefia zu besuchen -
ich glaube,
das erste oder zweite Mal -,
machte ich eine Woche lang
eine Art Lehre bei Odarte.
Er hat mir in dieser Woche gezeigt,
wie man Kpanlogos flickt.
Als sie zusammen zum Lederhändler
gehen, werden Erinnerungen wach.
Hier hatte ich
meine erste Trommellektion.
Als ich herunterkam,
sass mein Lehrer unter dem Baum
und ich habe ihn
zum ersten Mal gesehen.
Auf dieser Bühne
haben wir immer geprobt
mit dem Ghana Cultural Ballet.
Das Fell für die Trommeln
muss möglichst dünn sein,
aber dennoch stabil.
Siehst du das Loch?
- Ja.
Wir prüfen,
ob das Ziegenleder ein Loch hat.
Das hier hat kein Loch.
Das hier ist gut.
Ja, das denke ich auch.
Yeah, it's okay.
Mefia und ich sind fast fertig
mit dem Einkauf.
Zum Abendessen gibt es im Hotel
geräucherten Fisch.
Die Auswahl ist riesig,
probieren ist erwünscht.
Mmh!
* Sie spricht
in einer Fremdsprache. *
Das habe ich noch gar nicht gesehen -
ist sie deine Trägerin?
Ja, das ist in Ghana so.
Es gibt Trägerfrauen.
Ist das ein Beruf, Trägerfrau?
Okay.
Danach muss ich sie bezahlen.
Aber es kostet nicht viel.
Die Trägerinnen sind meist
junge Frauen aus dem Norden Ghanas.
Dort gibt es nur wenig Arbeit,
deshalb kommen sie in die Hauptstadt.
In Accra boomt die Wirtschaft.
Ghana ist ein Land
mit sehr vielen Rohstoffen.
Gold ist bis heute
das wichtigste Exportgut.
Man nannte das Land deshalb
früher auch Goldküste.
Die Kolonialmächte begannen früh,
Ghana auszubeuten.
Es war der grösste Handelsplatz
für Sklaven.
Die befestigten Forts an der Küste
erinnern an das dunkle Kapitel.
1957 befreite sich Ghana
vom British Empire
und rief als erstes
schwarzafrikanisches Land
seine Unabhängigkeit aus.
Heute gilt es als politisch stabil.
Aber ein Viertel der Bevölkerung
ist immer noch arm.
It can go.- Yeah.
- And now this one.
Meine Mutter
hat mir den Rat gegeben:
"Wenn du einen Menschen
besser kennenlernen willst,
iss mit ihm."
"Wenn du ihn noch besser
kennenlernen willst,
mach mit ihm eine Reise."
* Fernöstlich anmutende Musik *
Sharon und Mathias Manser reisten
viel, bevor sie Eltern wurden.
Jetzt ist samstags Backtag.
Und das gleich im grossen Stil:
Immer mehr Bestellungen
von Bekannten und Freunden gehen ein.
Ein harter Tag.
Viel zu viel.
Zu viel gibt es nicht.
Höchstens zu wenig Zeit
und zu wenig Mehl.
Die Chinesen lieben Schweizer Brot,
v.a. Sharon's Special.
Wir nennen es so.
(Flüsternd) Zopf.
Während der Woche arbeitet Mathias
als Qualitätsmanager
bei einer Schweizer Firma.
Sein Organisationstalent
drückt auch zu Hause durch.
Ich werde
mit dem Sauerteigbrot anfangen.
Dann kommt das Five-Seeds-Brot,
also das Vollkornbrot mit Kernen.
Dann werden wir
nach Plan weitermachen.
Dann sind wir planmässig um
ca. 15-15.30 Uhr fertig mit Backen.
Okay so?
- Okay.
Nein, hier ist es zu dick
und da zu dünn.
Wo ist das Backblech?
Sachte, sachte.
Sachte!
Mir ist die Form sehr wichtig
und die Qualität,
die wir unseren Kunden
und Freunden bieten.
So schlecht
bin ich nun auch wieder nicht.
Dir ist das halt wichtiger.
Manchmal gibt's auch Streit,
aber wir gehören zu den Menschen,
die sich schnell wieder vertragen.
Das ist noch nicht fertig, oder?
Zeig mal. Es ist okay.
- Ist es nicht.
Doch.
- Es ist nicht okay.
So läuft's: Ich sage, es sei okay,
er sagt, es sei nicht okay.
Es ist auch ein Beziehungstest.
Wir arbeiten als Team zusammen,
wir gehen nicht einfach
zusammen shoppen oder so.
Das hier ist etwas anderes.
Seit der Geburt des kleinen Jonathan
wurde die Paarzeit noch rarer.
Sharons Mutter hütet ihn.
Sie lebt mit der jungen Familie
unter einem Dach.
* Fernöstlich anmutende Musik *
Sie ist Zopf-Shape-Meisterin.
So süss!
Von den USA
nach Langenthal im Kanton Bern.
Hier ist das neue Zuhause
von Brigitte Howard.
Vor zwei Tagen
kehrte sie in die Schweiz zurück -
für immer.
Es ist nicht ganz flach.
Ich hoffe, es hält trotzdem.
Montana war zehn Jahre ihre Heimat
und die ihres Mannes Jay.
Aber das Heimweh
nach ihren beiden Töchtern,
die sie in der Schweiz
zurückgelassen hatte,
hat sie fast zerrissen.
Ich beginne bei der Tür,
dann geht man im Uhrzeigersinn
durch die Wohnung.
Das Fenster ist offen.
Ich lasse Fenster und Tür offen,
damit hinaus kann, was drin wäre.
Und auch,
damit der Rauch hinausgeht,
für alle anderen ringsum.
* Mystische Musik *
Den Raum ausräuchern -
dieses Ritual hat Brigitte
von Jay übernommen,
der Native American ist.
Ihre Gedanken sind oft bei ihm.
Vor Kurzem hatte Jay
eine Krebsoperation.
In zwei Monaten
soll er in die Schweiz nachreisen.
Noch nie waren die beiden
so lange getrennt.
Hey!
- Hi sweety!
Hi baby.
Wie geht's?
Du siehst wunderbar aus.
Ich bin so glücklich.
Das wird grossartig hier.
Es ist so schön.
Du wirst es lieben.
Wie geht's dir?
- Du fehlst mir.
Die letzten zwei Nächte
waren schrecklich.
Aber es geht mir
schon viel, viel besser.
Good!
- Bald kommen die Fäden raus.
Morgen, ja?
Morgen um 13.30 Uhr.
- Okay.
Wie geht's Boobo?
- Er vermisst dich so sehr.
Du fehlst mir.
- Du fehlst mir noch mehr.
Mach das Schlafzimmer bereit,
ich komme bald.
Okay. Ich liebe dich, Baby.
Bis bald. Bye!
Es ist verrückt.
Man merkt erst,
wie stark eine Beziehung ist,
wenn man weg ist, wenn man
für längere Zeit getrennt ist.
Wir waren jetzt zehn Jahre zusammen.
Wie er gesagt hat:
"I feel lost."
Wenn man plötzlich dasteht
und alles wieder selbst machen muss.
* Klingel *
Hallo!
Oh,
sie bringt mir einen Blumenstock!
Es ist eher ein Patient.
Ein Patient,
den ich gesundpflegen muss?
Ja,
die Katzen haben ihn angefressen.
Aber er schafft es.
Wir geben ihm
ein paar Notfalltropfen ins Wasser.
Etwas Bananenschale.
- Nein, Bachblüten.
Dewi ist Brigittes jüngere Tochter.
Hi!
- Hast du gut geschlafen?
Ja, mega, ich war k.o., knock-out.
Was hast du mir gebracht?
Ich weiss nicht ...
Ich dachte,
es ist hier wohl noch nicht so voll.
Nein, ich habe noch nicht so viel
im Kühlschrank.
Das siehst du richtig.
Tomaten, Mehl,
etwas Trockenfleisch, Müesli.
Und noch ein feines Dessert.
- Oh!
Die haben etwas gelitten.
Aber sie sehen lecker aus.
Die Fahrt war etwas kurvig.
(Lachend) Macht gar nichts.
Wir recyceln alles.
Als Brigitte vor zehn Jahren
zu Jay in die USA zog,
hatte sie ihre beiden Töchter
aus erster Ehe
in der Schweiz zurückgelassen.
Dewi lebte bei ihrem Vater.
Das war für alle nicht ganz einfach.
Es gibt immer Momente,
in denen man sich Mama wünscht.
Aber ich würde ihr nichts vorwerfen.
Es war okay für mich.
Manchmal ist es doch härter
als erwartet.
Also ...
Als ich ging, waren sie Teenager,
jetzt sind sie erwachsene Frauen.
Wie wollen wir es machen?
Hier unten hochheben?
Nicht einfach stossen?
- Ich weiss nicht.
Es sieht nicht so aus,
als würde etwas passieren.
Dann platzieren wir noch
dein armes Baby.
Wohin soll er?
* Lockere Musik *
* Klingel *
Schau her!
- Hallo!
Noch mehr Besuch kommt:
die Nachbarn von oben.
Man kennt sich noch von früher.
Bist du gut gereist?
... etwas vorbeibringen,
was du brauchst.
Ja, der Schlüssel zur Garage.
- Ja, genau.
Im Kulturzentrum von Accra
hat Mefia alle Hände voll zu tun.
Nie hätte sie gedacht,
dass sie mal Hotelmanagerin wird.
Als sie mit 15 ganz allein
vom Land nach Accra kam,
hat sie auch schlechte Erfahrungen
gemacht.
Bis sie im Haushalt von Lizzy
untergekommen ist.
Wir haben uns
noch gar nicht richtig kennengelernt.
I'm Mona.
Nice to meet you.
I'm Lizzy.
Lizzy ist für Mefia wie eine Mutter
und ist fast jeden Tag hier.
Very good. She ...
Mefia hat mir erzählt,
dass sie dir viel verdankt.
Z.B. ihre Unabhängigkeit.
Ja.
Ich habe meinen Kindern beigebracht,
dass sie arbeiten sollen.
Wenn du einen Job hast,
brauchst du niemanden mehr.
Du kannst alles selber machen.
Ja.
Bist du stolz auf Mefia?
Ja, ich bin stolz.
Sie ist eine starke Frau.
Ich lerne viel von ihr.
Ich bin auch unabhängig.
Aber manchmal
braucht sogar Lizzy Hilfe -
z.B. wenn das Auto streikt.
Das Wasser.
Wenn du weiterfährst,
kriegst du Probleme.
Wir sollten jemanden holen,
der sich damit auskennt.
Ich habe schon herumtelefoniert.
Wenn du weiterfährst,
geht der Motor kaputt.
Du warst ja auch mal in der Schweiz.
Erzähl mal, wie war das?
Yes.
- So tell me: How was it?
Ich war mit Beda in einem Klub.
To a club?
- Yes.- Oh, really?
Ja, und mein Mann schimpfte:
"Wieso gehst du in den Klub
und nicht zur Kirche?"
Ich sagte Nein, ich ging Tanzen.
* Lockere Musik *
Wie wohl die meisten Jugendlichen
auf dieser Welt
verbringen auch
die beiden Söhne Evan und Levin
ihre Freizeit gerne mit Gamen.
Die Bar
füllt sich langsam mit Gästen.
Ein Kulturzentrum zu realisieren,
hätte Beda nie allein geschafft.
Die Bauleitung
sei fest in Frauenhand gewesen.
Das haben Mefia und Lizzy gemacht.
Ja.
- Ihre Mutter.
Auch als wir noch nicht
hier gewohnt haben,
hat sie zum Bau geschaut.
Sie ist super dafür.
Sie hat schon andere Hausbauten
geleitet.
Sie weiss,
wie sie die Leute angehen muss,
wie man mit ihnen verhandelt.
Würdest du dir das nicht zutrauen?
Nein.
Um das Pannenfahrzeug von Lizzy
versammeln sich
mehr und mehr Menschen.
Und jeder weiss Bescheid.
Das ist der Trick:
Man muss hier alle Leute kennen.
Das ist bei dir der Nachteil,
weil du kein Local bist.
Kann dir Mefia dabei helfen?
- Ja, sicher.
Es ist richtig,
man muss viele Leute kennen.
Wenn man natürlich wichtige
oder ranghohe Leute kennt,
kann einem das hier sehr helfen.
Viel mehr als in der Schweiz.
Auch dort gibt es Vitamin B
und es hilft, wenn man Leute kennt,
um z.B. einen Job zu bekommen,
aber hier ist es wirklich krass.
Wenn du bei der Polizei
die richtigen Leute kennst,
kannst du noch so blöd tun -
es passiert dir nichts.
Push, push!
* Verspielte, glockige Musik *
2010 war Backen
noch nicht so verbreitet wie heute.
Ich dachte, das sei echt cool.
Man kann Cookies, Brot
und sogar Kuchen backen.
Backen ist also nicht nur
sein Hobby, sondern auch meines.
Das hatten wir beide
in unserem Rucksack.
Unabhängig voneinander
brachten wir diese Leidenschaft
fürs Backen schon mit.
In der chinesischen Stadt Wuxi
ist es Nachmittag geworden.
Ich bin fertig mit dem Zopf.
Wirklich? Okay.
Wann fängst du mit den Cranberries
und den Rosinen an?
Ich beginne nun mit dem Teig.
Gut, perfekt.
Ihr Backprojekt wird immer grösser.
Deshalb haben sie die Garage
zu einer semiprofessionellen Bäckerei
umgebaut.
Es bringt einen kleinen Zustupf.
Aber wir machen es nicht
wegen des Gelds,
sondern weil es uns Spass macht.
Obwohl ich sehr müde bin
und der Tag fast vorbei ist,
geniesse ich das Backen immer sehr.
Das Backen ist wirklich jeden Tag
eine Freude.
* Hupen *
Schnell, schnell! Komm rein!
* Sie spricht chinesisch. *
Zeig dich doch kurz.
Hello!
Das Brotbacken ist auch ein sozialer
Event für Sharon und Mathias.
Das ist ein Geschenk:
ein selbst gemachter Kuchen.
Heute ist unser Hochzeitstag.
So könnt ihr alle
ein wenig mitfeiern.
* Sie sprechen chinesisch. *
* Sharon lacht. *
Surprise!
Sogar an ihrem Hochzeitstag
wird bei Mathias und Sharon gebacken
statt gefeiert.
* Fernöstlich anmutende Musik *
Vorsicht, da ist Brot drin.
Nach 9 Std. hat Mathias
über 80 Brote gebacken.
Wir stossen an unsere Grenzen.
- Yes.
V.a. ich.
Ich arbeite die ganze Woche
und am Wochenende
backe ich einen ganzen Tag.
Den Sonntag verbringe ich
mit Jonathan, unserem Baby.
Backen ist ein Hobby, wir lieben es,
aber wenn es keinen Spass mehr
macht, hören wir auf.
Yes.
Jasper! Hallo, Jasper.
Hallo! Hey!
- Mathias.
Der Kontakt mit Freunden,
die Brot abholen,
entschädigt sie
für ihre Anstrengung.
Zi Fong Giang ist Schweizer
mit chinesischen Wurzeln.
Heute hatten wir megaviel.
Es war heftig. 87 Brote, schau mal.
- Hoppla!
Ich kaufe das Brot, weil ich in der
Schweiz immer Brot gegessen habe.
Jetzt bin ich sieben Jahre in China
und hier gibt es das nicht.
Mathias macht authentisches Brot
und v.a. Zopf.
Bürli oder Baguettes
bekommt man ab und zu,
aber Zopf bekommt man nirgends.
Deshalb bin ich froh,
dass Mathias das anbietet.
Wir haben noch einen Cake,
einen Gugelhopf.
Wann hast du zum letzten Mal
einen solchen gegessen?
Oder willst du ihn
gleich Jasper geben?
Ja, ich denke, er hat Hunger.
Jasper, möchtest du?
* Sie sprechen chinesisch. *
Just try, Jasper.
* Fernöstlich anmutende Musik *
You see Jonathan?
He's super excited.
Was wir zusammen aufgebaut haben,
seit wir verheiratet sind,
wird immer hier sein.
Auch wenn wir nicht mehr hier sind,
ist es noch da.
* Lockere Trommelmusik *
Für ihren Traum
eines Kulturzentrums in Ghana
haben Beda und Mefia
mit den beiden Söhnen
das Leben in der Schweiz
hinter sich gelassen.
Gewonnen haben sie eine Grossfamilie
und einen Alltag,
in dem man zusammenhält
und der sicher nie langweilig wird.
* Fröhliche, glockige Musik *
Werdet ihr hier in Ghana bleiben
oder geht ihr irgendwann zurück?
Ich bin so glücklich hier.
Meine Familie ist auch hier.
Ich werde sowieso wieder
in der Schweiz Ferien machen.
Aber ob ich wieder dorthin ziehe -
ich weiss es noch nicht.
Wir schauen mal.
Bist du auch so diplomatisch
wie Mefia?
Ja, mir geht es ähnlich.
Vieles ist hier etwas ungewiss.
Es ist ein Abenteuer.
Man weiss oft nicht recht,
was auf einen zukommt.
Es kann sein, dass wir hier sterben
und ich hier begraben werde,
es kann aber auch sein,
dass wir in 10 oder 20 Jahren
in der Schweiz etwas machen wollen,
oder halb-halb.
Vieles ist möglich.
Wir lassen es offen.
Ich möchte mich nicht festlegen.
Aber ich würde sagen, die nächsten
zehn Jahre sind wir sicher hier.
Was wünscht ihr euch für eure Kinder?
Was denkst du,
werden Evan und Levin hier gross
oder kehren sie vielleicht
irgendwann zurück?
Ich glaube, Levin will zurück.
Er möchte studieren
und später dort arbeiten.
Evan ist noch klein.
Von ihm weiss ich es noch nicht.
Aber von Levin schon.
Dann werde ich wissen, wie es ist,
wenn der Sohn
auf einen anderen Kontinent abhaut.
Ja, so ist es:
Wir sind ein Paar
aus zwei verschiedenen Kontinenten.
Jetzt müssen wir damit dealen.
- Ja.
Mefia und Beda - ein mutiges Paar.
Dank dem Schritt in die andere Welt
konnten sie auch sich selbst
noch mal neu erfinden.
Es war dieser Moment,
als ich ihr Piercing sah.
Sie sagte irgendetwas -
bla, bla, bla -
und ich dachte nur darüber nach,
was es wohl für ein Gefühl wäre,
sie zu küssen.
Liebe kennt keine Grenzen,
aber Staaten kennen sie eben schon.
Sie bekommt zu spüren,
wer sich in jemanden
aus einem anderen Land verliebt.
Migrationsbestimmungen, Bürokratie,
der ganze Papierkrieg -
für viele binationale Paare
eine echte Bewährungsprobe.
Andrea und Pedro haben diesen
Nervenkrieg monatelang durchgemacht.
Schläft sie wohl noch?
Es ist Sonntagmorgen.
Hallo, guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen, Andrea.
Dürfen wir reinkommen?
- Klar.
Vielen Dank.
Reisen ist Andrea Götz'
grosse Leidenschaft.
Vor zweieinhalb Jahren
wollte sie einen grossen Trip
durch Südamerika machen.
In Kolumbien traf sie
den Übersetzer Pedro.
Später wurden sie ein Paar.
Pedro besuchte sie
während drei Monaten in der Schweiz.
Kurz danach flog Andrea
wieder nach Kolumbien -
mit etwas ganz Speziellem im Gepäck.
Es ist sogar noch im Plastik.
* Andrea lacht. *
Ich wollte schon schauen,
was für ein Kleid ich mitnehme.
Es konnte kein riesiges Kleid sein.
- Nein, wegen dem Koffer.
Ich hatte nicht so viel Gepäck.
Deshalb habe ich
ein Zwischending gewählt.
Man möchte ja doch etwas ...
So sieht das aus.
Megaschön.
Halt es dir mal hin.
So hättest du heiraten wollen?
- So werde ich heiraten!
Wann?
- Das wissen wir noch nicht.
Die Traumhochzeit
am Strand von Kolumbien ist geplatzt.
Die Dokumente
seien nicht vollständig,
wurde ihnen von Venezuela gesagt,
der Heimat Pedros.
Ein Land, das für seine
komplizierte Bürokratie bekannt ist.
Andrea sagt:
"Kein Staat der Welt gibt uns ohne
Heirat eine Chance, zusammenzuleben."
* Verspielte Musik *
Der Nägelimoosweiher hat Pedro
bei seinem Schweiz-Besuch
besonders gefallen.
Hier verrät mir Andrea, warum sie
der Pandemie ihre Liebe verdankt.
Du bist allein
nach Südamerika gereist.
Nicht auf der Suche nach einem Mann,
sondern auf der Suche nach ...
Vielleicht nach ein wenig Freiheit,
nach Abwechslung.
Danach, nicht immer im Arbeitsalltag
gefangen zu sein.
Ich wollte einfach mal
in den Tag leben können,
frei entscheiden können:
"Heute mache ich das
und am nächsten Tag jenes."
Und dann?
Das ist unser erstes
gemeinsames Bild.
Er sieht etwas seltsam aus.
- Er sieht ganz speziell aus.
Er dachte wohl:
"Schon wieder ein Touri-Foto."
Hättest du dir damals
vorstellen können,
dass der da neben dir irgendwann
der Mann deines Lebens wird?
Nie im Leben.
- Wirklich?
Ich ging dorthin
und wollte meine Reise starten.
Ecuador, Peru, Bolivien,
Argentinien, Chile, alles.
Ich konnte niemanden brauchen.
Und auf einmal machte es zack
und nichts funktionierte mehr.
Alle sind wie Bienen herumgewuselt,
alle Touristen mussten nach Hause.
Corona.
- Corona.
Und dann?
- Ich wollte nicht nach Hause.
Er war der Einzige in Santa Marta,
den ich kannte.
Er hatte keinen Job mehr.
Ich hatte ein Airbnb, aber ich
brauchte Hilfe beim Wasserschleppen.
Du hast dich bei ihm gemeldet,
weil du Unterstützung gebraucht hast.
Ja, einen Wasserträger.
Am Anfang fand er es okay.
Dann hat er gemerkt,
dass das Airbnb schön war.
Er hatte nur ein kleines Zimmer ohne
Tageslicht, was nicht sehr cool war.
So wohnte er?
- Ja, in einem WG-Zimmer.
Er merkte, dass es cool war. Also
blieb er manchmal und kochte noch.
Wann hast du mehr in ihm gesehen?
Hat es den Moment gegeben, als du
gemerkt hast: "Ich bin verliebt"?
Einen richtigen Moment nicht.
Aber irgendwann war es einfach da.
Ich merkte, dass ich ohne ihn
gar nicht mehr weiterreisen wollte.
"Eigentlich könnte der Lockdown noch
länger gehen, das macht mir nichts."
Das war dann sozusagen
das erste offizielle Foto.
Als Paar?
- Ja.
Die Hoffnung,
bald zusammenleben zu können,
geben Andrea und Pedro nicht auf.
Aber das Hochzeitsvisum
fehlt immer noch.
* Verspielte Musik *
Sind wir nicht ganz
gleicher Meinung, sage ich:
"Machen wir es so, wie du willst."
Ausser es ist wirklich etwas ...
Aber meistens sage ich: "Wenn du
glücklich bist, bin ich es auch."
Nein,
wir suchen nach einem Kompromiss.
* Rhythmische
südamerikanische Musik *
Canoa ist ein ehemaliges Fischerdorf
an der Küste des Pazifik.
Mit einem der schönsten Strände
Ecuadors.
Etwa 7'000 Menschen leben hier.
Einer davon
ist der Schweizer Tom Friedli.
Er und seine Lebensgefährtin Angie
führen zusammen dieses Hotel.
Buenos días.
Amorcita!
Hola, mi amor.
Wie geht's?
- Sehr gut, Liebster. Und dir?
Früh dran, wie immer?
Die Kleine?
- Sie ist drin.
Sie macht noch Hausaufgaben
für die Schule.
Sie muss dann zum Unterricht.
Carlita ist zehn und Angies Tochter.
* Er flüstert auf Spanisch. *
Von einem Hotel direkt am Meer
träumte Tom schon,
als er in Europa
noch als Banker arbeitete.
Und lateinamerikanische Frauen
hätten es ihm schon immer angetan.
Angie hat er
übers Internet kennengelernt.
Nach vielen Hindernissen
funkte es letztlich auch bei ihr.
Er war der erste Schweizer,
den ich kennengelernt habe.
Er ist so fürsorglich
und aufmerksam.
Meine Freundinnen sagten: "Zeig ihn
her, wir wollen auch so einen."
"Bring Schokolade mit und finde uns
auch einen Single mit Geld."
"Hat er keinen Bruder oder Cousin?
Bring sie her, stell sie uns vor."
Die Ecuadorianer sind ganz anders,
sie haben halt oft zwei bis drei
Frauen - wenn nicht mehr.
Manchmal staune selbst ich -
und ich habe das Gefühl,
ich habe schon viel gesehen
auf der Welt.
Aber hier in Ecuador ist es
in dieser Beziehung schon extrem.
Weisst du noch,
der Typ, der innerhalb einer Woche
mit zwei verschiedenen Frauen
zu uns kam?
Ah ja.
Die Europäer sind da ganz anders.
Wenn sie nichts mehr von dir wollen,
machen sie Schluss.
Ich habe Thomas schon oft gesagt:
"Wenn du mich nicht mehr willst,
dann sag es mir."
Ich weiss.
Aber ich liebe dich so sehr.
* Lockere Musik *
2009 nahm Tom zum ersten Mal
mit Angie Kontakt auf.
Aber es brauchte noch
ganze sechs Jahre,
bis sie als Paar und Patchworkfamilie
zusammenkamen.
Endlich ist er da:
der Tag, dem Brigitte Howard
seit zwei Monaten entgegenfiebert.
Ihr Mann Jay kommt aus den USA
in die Schweiz - für immer.
Gelandet, sie sind gelandet.
Yes, yes, yes!
So lange waren die beiden
noch nie getrennt.
Jay hatte vor Kurzem
eine Krebsoperation.
Das bereitet Brigitte Sorgen.
Wir müssen jetzt einfach abwarten,
schauen und hoffen,
dass es nicht gestreut hat.
Wir gehen so schnell wie möglich
zum Arzt,
damit er mit der Chemo
beginnen kann.
Ja ... es ist ...
Wir wollen sicher
noch mindestens 25 Jahre ...
Elf haben wir schon.
14 Jahre müssen wir
auf jeden Fall noch.
Think positive.
Brigitte!
Wo kommst du denn her?
* Brigitte lacht. *
* Sanfte Musik *
* Kuss *
Glücklich?
- Ja, ich bin glücklich.
Ich war so aufgeregt.
- Warum?
Einfach so aufgeregt.
- Wegen ihm?
Nein, wegen dir.
Ich bin so erleichtert,
dass alles gut gegangen ist.
Gut, hier zu sein.
Hey Boobo! Hey boy!
Hey boy!
Es geht mir prima.
Endlich sind wir zusammen.
Wir drei Musketiere.
Hey baby.
Hi!
Es ist gut.
Jetzt bin ich komplett.
Ist er nicht gross geworden?
Er war so klein, als sie ging.
Ja, er ist in die Höhe geschossen.
Ich kann es kaum glauben.
Show me.
- Okay, straight ...
In der nächsten Folge
von "Hin und weg":
Hello Switzerland!
In China ist das selbst gemachte
Schweizer Brot heiss begehrt.
Aber Sharon und Mathias
bringt der Stress an ihre Grenze.
Wir sind ein Team. Ein Team!
Relax!
Wenn er das sagt:
"Relax" oder "beeil dich" ...
Das bringt sie zur Weissglut.
In Langenthal
startet der Native American Jay
in sein neues Leben
mit Brigitte in der Schweiz.
Trotz seiner Krankheit
glaubt er fest daran,
dass seine Zeit
noch nicht abgelaufen ist.
Ich mache mir keine Sorgen.
Der Schöpfer hat uns hier vereint.
Ich soll noch nicht sterben.
Und gar nicht romantisch war es,
als Tom seine Angie vor elf Jahren
um ein erstes Date bat.
Sie sagte,
sie müsse mir leider etwas sagen.
Sie sei schwanger.
Für mich brach eine Welt zusammen.
Eine Welt ...
Ein Traum platzte für mich.
# Take my hand.
# Together we will be,
forever you and me, take my hand.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Madeleine Gassner - 2022